♪ ♪
>> Juan: STUDENTS RETURNED TO
STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL IN
FLORIDA TODAY.
WE HAVE BREAKING DEVELOPMENTS ON
THE INVESTIGATION.
FLORIDA'S HOUSE HAS ISSUED
SUBPOENAS TO THE BROWARD COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE, SCHOOL BOARD,
AND SEVERAL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
ITS EVALUATION OF WHAT WENT
WRONG.
WILL SHERIFF ISRAEL RELEASED THE
SURVEILLANCE VIDEO SHOWING THE
POLICE RESPONSE OF THE MASS
SHOOTING?
A LOT OF CONTROVERSY OVER THE
RESPONSE.
IN THE NATION'S CAPITAL, THE
PRESIDENT SAT DOWN WITH MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS FROM BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE TO DISCUSS CHANGES TO
OUR NATION'S GUN LAWS.
>> WE ARE GOING TO COME UP WITH
SOME IDEAS.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN PUT THOSE IDEAS
IN A VERY BIPARTISAN BILL.
IT WOULD BE SO BEAUTIFUL TO HAVE
ONE BILL EVERYBODY COULD
SUPPORT.
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING VERY
DECISIVE.
YOU CAN TAKE THE GUNS AWAY
IMMEDIATELY FROM PEOPLE THAT YOU
CAN JUDGE EASILY ARE MENTALLY
ILL.
I DON'T WANT MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE
TO BE HAVING GUNS.
URATE MOVIES FOR DIFFERENT
THINGS.
MAYBE YOU HAVE TO RATE THEM FOR
TERROR, FOR WHAT THEY ARE DOING
AND WHAT THEY ARE ALL ABOUT.
SOME OF YOU PEOPLE ARE PETRIFIED
OF THE NRA.
YOU CAN'T BE PETRIFIED.
THEY WANT TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT AND
THEY'RE GOING TO DO WHAT'S
RIGHT.
I REALLY BELIEVE THAT.
>> Juan: KIMBERLY, THE
PRESIDENT CAME UP WITH SOME
BASIC IDEAS LIKE NOT SELLING
GUNS TO PEOPLE UNDER 21.
HE WANTS MORE OF A UNIVERSAL,
NOT QUITE -- BETTER BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
THEN THERE'S THE QUESTION
SITTING OUT THERE ABOUT ASSAULT
WEAPONS.
>> Kimberly: I THINK IT MAKES
SENSE.
WHEN YOU SIT HOME AND LISTEN TO
THIS AND THINK ABOUT THE
PERSPECTIVE OF, WE WOULD LIKE
SOME UNIFORMITY AND CONFORMITY
IN TERMS OF BACKGROUND CHECKS.
WE WOULD LIKE ALL THE STATES TO
HAVE SOME WAS OF A SIMILAR
BACKGROUND CHECK THAT IS
THOROUGH AND COMPREHENSIVE AND
THAT PEOPLE COMPLY WITH BY
TURNING IN THE INFORMATION,
UPDATING THE DATABASE TO MAKE
SURE IT'S CURRENT AND ACTIVE.
IT CALLS FOR THAT BECAUSE IT'S
SO IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AND TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE,
IF THEY ARE TROUBLED AND HAVING
ISSUES, BUT THE MOST RECENT
INFORMATION IS COMPILED AND
UPLOADED IN THE SYSTEM TO BE
AVAILABLE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT,
DIFFERENT AGENCIES, MENTAL
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS TO
KNOW WHO THEY ARE DEALING WITH.
I WANT THAT TOO.
YOU WANT THAT KIND OF
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE BOARD SO
IF YOU GO TO ALABAMA, IT'S NOT
DIFFERENT THAN IF YOU GO TO
CALIFORNIA.
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
RESPECTING THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS AND THE SECOND AMENDMENT
AND PEOPLE'S RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS.
PART OF THAT INCLUDES THESE
CHECKS.
>> Juan: THE PRESIDENT SAID HE
STILL LIKES THE IDEA OF ARMING
TEACHERS.
HE SAID HE UNDERSTANDS A LOT OF
YOU DON'T LIKE THE IDEA.
WE HAD A REPORT OF A TEACHER
WITH A GUN HAVING AN INCIDENT IN
GEORGIA.
>> Jesse: THAT IS TOUGH.
I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF
DISAGREEMENT ON THE ISSUE.
DEPENDS WHERE YOU ARE IN THE
COUNTRY.
PEOPLE IN MANHATTAN THINK THAT
IS WILD AND YOU GO ANYWHERE ELSE
AND THEY THINK THAT'S NORMAL.
A LOT OF STATES ALREADY DO IT.
THERE WAS A KEY MOMENT OF WERE
THE PRESIDENT WAS KIND OF
MOCKING SENATOR TOOMEY FROM
PENNSYLVANIA.
THEY ASKED HIM ABOUT RAISING THE
AGE LIMIT TEN HE SAID
MR. PRESIDENT, THERE IS A LOT OF
18, 19, 20-YEAR-OLD MEN AND
WOMEN IN PENNSYLVANIA THAT WANT
TO USE AN AR FOR FUN, TARGET,
HUNTING.
WHY SHOULD WE DENY LAW-ABIDING
PEOPLE THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
THE PRESIDENT SAID ALL RIGHT, HE
LOOKED AT SENATOR MANCHIN, HE
SAID YOU HAVE TO GET TOGETHER ON
THAT.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A CRITICAL
ISSUE.
ON THE BROWARD COUNTY THING, WE
ARE LOOKING AT INFORMATION FROM
SOURCES THAT SAID PEOPLE WHO
SHOWED UP, THE POLICE OFFICERS,
WERE TOLD NOT TO GO IN UNLESS
THEY HAVE BODY CAMERAS.
NONE OF THEM HAD BODY CAMERAS.
THE EMTs WERE TOLD NOT TO GO
IN.
ONE OF THE EMTs TOLD FOX NEWS
EVERYTHING I WAS TRAINED ON MASS
CASUALTY EVENT SAID THEY DID THE
WRONG THING.
TRAINING SINCE COLUMBINE HAS
BEEN FIRST RESPONDERS, POLICE GO
IN IMMEDIATELY WITH PARAMEDICS.
THEY HAD A DE-ESCALATION POLICY
AT THE BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND THEY HAD ANOTHER
PROGRAM CALLED THE PROMISE
PROGRAM WHERE THEY DON'T ARREST
STUDENTS FOR CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
YOU GET TO THE POINT WHERE HE
APPOINTS HIS FRIEND TO THAT
POSITION.
HE WAS INVOLVED IN THE
FORT LAUDERDALE SHOOTING AT THE
AIRPORT WHICH WENT HORRIBLY
WRONG.
HE WAS CASTIGATED FOR THAT.
RADIO TRANSMISSIONS WENT DOWN,
THE FORT LAUDERDALE SHOOTINGS.
RADIO TRANSMISSIONS SUSPICIOUSLY
WENT DOWN IN THIS SHOOTING TOO.
HE IS SAYING THEY CALLED THE
HOUSE 23 TIMES.
TURNS OUT IT WAS TWICE THAT.
THIS SHERIFF IS A REAL VILLAIN
AND I DON'T LIKE WHAT HE'S DONE
AND HOW HE'S CONDUCTED HIMSELF.
LOOKS LIKE THE FLORIDA
LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO TAKE
SOME ACTION AGAINST THIS GUY.
>> Juan: THERE ARE A LOT OF
STORIES IN THERE BUT WE HAVE TO
MOVE ON.
DICK'S SPORTING GOODS HAS SAID
THEY WILL NOT SELL ASSAULT
WEAPONS.
THEY AREN'T GOING TO SELL ANY
GUN TO SOMEONE UNDER 21, AND
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO SELL
HIGH-CAPACITY MAGAZINES.
>> Dana: IT COULD BE THIS IS A
GOOD P.R. MOVE FOR THEM BUT YOU
ARE MAKING A DECISION ABOUT
SELLING A PRODUCT.
MAYBE THEIR SALES WEREN'T VERY
GOOD.
MAYBE IT WON'T HURT THEM THAT
BAD ON THE BOTTOM LINE.
MAYBE IT WILL INCREASE SALES OF
PEOPLE DECIDE THAT'S A GOOD
PLACE TO GO.
IF YOU DON'T MIND HIM I WANT TO
COMMENT ON JEFF SESSIONS THE
PRESIDENT IS HAVING.
THERE IS SOMETHING VERY SPECIAL
ABOUT THEM.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU THINK, DO
YOU REMEMBER THE OPEN SESSION
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD ON OBAMACARE
EARLY ON.
PAUL RYAN WAS THERE IN THE
PRESIDENT TOOK A REAL SHOT AT
PAUL RYAN AND McCAIN.
THAT WAS 2009, MAYBE EARLY 2010.
IT SET BIPARTISAN RELATIONS WAY
BACK.
IF IT DOESN'T GET BACK ON TRACK
UNTIL THERE'S MOMENTS WITH
CRISES ON THE BUDGET WHERE THEY
HAVE TO GET TOGETHER.
THE PRESIDENT IS CALLING EMBERS
OF THE SENATE BY THEIR FIRST
NAME, NOT DISRESPECTFULLY BUT IN
A WAY THAT IS QUITE FRIENDLY.
HE IS FORCING PEOPLE TO COME TO
THE TABLE.
IT'S NOT WITHOUT RISK TO HAVE
OPEN CAMERAS THERE.
ANYBODY COULD COME OUT AND SAY
ANYTHING.
I FIND THAT THE MEMBERS FEEL
CONFIDENT ENOUGH TO SAY
SOMETHING IN FRONT OF THE
PRESIDENT IN FRONT OF THE
CAMERAS THAT IS NOT SHOWBOATING.
IF THEY CONTINUE TO HAVE OPEN
FORUMS OR NOTHING RESULTS, THEN
THEY WILL GET OLD BUT RIGHT NOW
IT'S VERY SPECIAL.
>> Brian: WHAT'S MOST
IMPORTANT IS THE CONCLUSION AT
THE END.
WHEN STEVE SCALISE PUT HIS HAND
UP AND SAID I WANT TO PUT
CONCEALED CARRY AND THAT HE SAID
STEVE, I'M YOUR BIGGEST FAN BUT
NOT IN THIS BILL.
TO DIANNE FEINSTEIN, HE SAYS
WHAT YOU THINK?
MR. PRESIDENT, IF YOU TELL THEM,
THEY DO IT.
TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH, THIS
MAKES ME REALIZE WHY THE
APPRENTICE WORKED.
THE BOARD ROOM WAS REAL.
THAT'S THE WAY HE CONDUCTS HIS
LIFE.
THEY WOULD EDIT IT AND DO A
GOOD JOB BUT FOR THE MOST PART
THE CELEBRITIES SAT IN FRONT OF
HIM AND THEY WERE THE REAL
PEOPLE.
THIS TEAM OVER THE LAST FOUR
DAYS HAS SAT THESE PEOPLE AROUND
HIM AND SAID MR. PRESIDENT  , HE
SAT THERE.
JOE MANCHIN SAID I DON'T LIKE
BEING SENATOR BECAUSE I CAN'T
GET ANYTHING DONE.
AS GOVERNOR, I GOT TO DO THINGS.
NOW HE IS IN THE GAME.
HE SAID IF HE -- AND THIS WAS
OUR PRESIDENT IN 2013, WE WOULD
HAVE GOT STUFF PASSED AFTER
SANDY HOOK.
THAT IS A DEMOCRAT FROM
WEST VIRGINIA.
I KNOW HE NEEDS TO GET REELECTED
BUT STILL THAT WAS UNSOLICITED.
>> Juan: THIS IS THE
PRESIDENT'S STYLE.
WE WANT TO GET SOMETHING DONE.